momento de hablar de economía en france
24 y por ello le doy la bienvenida a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniel
empezamos en eeuu porque la operación de
red de oleoductos más grande del país
sigue suspendido está suspendida en tres
muy buenas noches desde el viernes por
cuenta de un ataque cibernético a
colonial pipeline que es la que opera
esta gigante red la empresa dijo que
espera tener su sistema funcionando
completamente a finales de esta semana
pero veamos andrés esta red es
importante porque porque sus casi 9000
kilómetros de oleoductos atraviesan al
menos 13 estados que van desde texas
hasta nueva jersey y se estima que
suministra casi la mitad del combustible
de toda esta zona que estamos viendo
temor por el posible desabastecimiento
entre sus principales clientes eso es lo
que hay incluidos varios aeropuertos
como el de atlanta que es el más
transitado del mundo el fbi concluyó que
el ataque es de un grupo de piratas
informáticos llamados darkside su modo
de operar es que bloquean el acceso a
los computadores de las empresas y piden
millonarios rescates para después
liberarlos
daniela un juez en méxico suspendió los
efectos de la nueva ley de hidrocarburos
enteros y andrés esta es una provisión
una suspensión provisional parcial de la
norma impulsada por el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador que le otorga al
estado plena autoridad para revocar
permisos ya existentes petroleros la ley
fue aprobada el mes pasado por el
congreso y ha sido bastante criticada
porque hay quienes dicen que establece
condiciones que sólo la estatal pemex
puede cumplir lo que va en contra de los
inversionistas privados algunos
inclusive la han tildado de
expropiatoria algo parecido sucedió con
la también polémica reforma eléctrica
recordemos que en marzo pasado el mismo
juez la suspendió y se convirtió en uno
de los principales rivales del
presidente quien lo acusa de corrupto
daniela el presidente de argentina
inició en portugal su gira por europa
alberto fernández y se reunió con el
primer ministro de portugal antonio
costa en la primera de varias reuniones
que tiene previstas en el 'viejo
continente' con una sola misión andrés
buscar apoyos para que el fondo
monetario internacional
y retrasar los pagos de una deuda de
unos 44 mil millones de dólares la
reunión sirvió además para que los
líderes discutieron sobre el acuerdo
comercial entre mercosur y la unión
europea
este acuerdo se logró en 2019 después de
20 años de negociaciones y podría
eliminar casi 5.000 millones de dólares
en aranceles anuales pero no ha sido
ratificado por las preocupaciones sobre
la deforestación en la amazonía
brasileña costa dijo que va a hacer todo
lo posible para lograrlo antes del 30 de
junio
daniela y en europa también por una
posible burbuja en los precios de la
vivienda porque hay sobre la siguiente
por varias décadas los precios han
venido subiendo eso no es noticia pero
en pandemia lo han hecho más por eso los
gobiernos están haciendo lo posible por
superar esa escasez de viviendas
el fenómeno se ve en general en todo el
continente pero hay tres ejemplos que le
voy a mostrar suecia planea cerrar un
aeropuerto de estocolmo para construir
alrededor de 30.000 nuevas viviendas en
el antiguo aeropuerto de tegel de berlín
cerrado en noviembre pasado
las autoridades planean construir más de
5000 apartamentos y la demanda de
trabajadores que se están quedando en
casa desesperados por un buen espacio
que se parezca más o menos a una oficina
ha contribuido al alza de los precios a
eso se suman los estímulos fiscales y
monetarios sin precedentes en reino
unido por ejemplo tercer ejemplo los
precios de la vivienda tuvieron en abril
su mayor subida mensual en más de 17
años esto hizo que el gobierno buscará
incentivos sobre todo para ayudar a los
compradores primerizos y le tengo un
dato de cierre en las ciudades que más
han subido de precios o en estocolmo
luxemburgo
moscú y bratislava y en contra y por el
contrario madrid en madrid han caído
indicadores del día daniela andrés 'wall
street' de cerró en rojo lastrado por la
caída en las grandes tecnológicas en
contra hace muchas de las acciones
europeas alcanzaron máximos históricos
gracias entre otros al aumento del
precio de las materias primas
este impulso de las materias primas
también ayudó a las bolsas de américa
latina como la mexicana nuestra cifra
del día 5 como 85 billones de dólares es
el cálculo de lo que cuesta en las
medidas
operación en proceso en la unión europea
para salir de la crisis esto es cuatro
veces el pib de méxico o veinte veces el
pib de colombia para compararlo daniela
hablando como siempre muchas gracias por
la información económica y ustedes
muchas gracias por acompañarnos los
invitamos a que continúen con toda
nuestra programación
[Música]